Mình sẽ mởi giới chức cảm ủ trí cho biết,
là gần năng là bác sức tận gộng mang in muốn trong năm 2018,
trong cái chính dịch trả nó tội phạm lưu đạo chục tuyến,
diễn ra từ quay thằng sau đến dữ tham người.
Các đối thượng thuộc 2 mới của tệ căn nhau,
bây đẹp đẹp điểm thuộc mới 30 tình thành trên cả nước.
Chỉ dịch đường đánh giá là quay mô lớn chứ từ cố,
thế hiện nấu lực cuy lịch của Phnom Bánh Chúc Việt sử li vẫn nạn lưu đạo mạc,
muốn cây thái lớn về kinh tế và ui tình của giá.
Nhà chí chế cảm ủ trí cho đa thủ dưới nhiều bằng chính địa tự,
truy tốt các y phạm cầm đau cũng như chục sất những người li quang.
Dời phân tinh nhận đệ,
nằm thấy nạn năm trong trí lượng lâu sai của cảm ủ trí cho,
nằm cùng cố chứ từ sau hội và hợp các trở chế hơn,
bếc nước lặng dân chẳng tội phạm mạng suyên địa dưới.